welcome back to another edition of
gadget lab show I am Michael colori I'm
Christina Bonnington and Christina you
were somewhere very interesting and
exciting this week yes I was at the
apple event at the yerba buena center
here in San Francisco you did actually
get a chance to tell us all about the
iphone 5 and then you got a chance to
touch it and experience it so what's it
like so it's it's an iphone it's lighter
the lightness was the most surprising
thing about it like it's it's noticeably
longer it's got a 4-inch display 1136 x
640 pixels and um but you pick it up and
it's so much lighter than the iphone 4
for us it's because it is more aluminum
in it than glass yeah so instead of that
full glass back it's got a brushed
aluminum back in that brushed aluminum
is also it's slightly textured so it's
not quite so smooth an your hand which i
like it adds a little bit of like
friction see it doesn't feel like the
phone's gonna slip out of your hand if
you're if your hands are like oily from
pizza there's something that's the
problem with lighter devices like the
things we've seen some of these android
phones where you know it's like a
plastic back and it's so light that it
just kind of feels like it's gonna it
there's not enough to hold it in your
hand you really have to grip it a little
bit right and it's also nice that it's
the same width as the current iphone
which for my size hands is like the
perfect size for my hand there's also a
new processor the a6 processor this is
apple's own correct yes yeah and it's
super fast you know upload basically
instantly we only had limited like hands
on time so we'll be testing that more
but from what I could tell it's very
fast phone okay and it goes on sale when
you can pre-order it starting 1201 am
September 14th and then it goes on sale
September 21st which is the friday after
so how much is it gonna cost me it's a
same pricing as always
16 gigs for 232 gigs for 360 4 gigs for
400 okay on contract so one of the
things that I did I wanted to touch on
is that it seems like it's a very
iterative design and it I know apples
been taking a lot of criticism about
this but it seems like at this point in
the product's life cycle there really
isn't too far they can go in any one
particular direction where it feel like
it looks a lot like the last iphone what
are your thoughts on that so I mean the
fact that you know it is it's definitely
iterative it's just like kind of what
we've seen before but a little bit
different but it kind of you know the
iphone has its own identity and I think
that it's smart for Apple to kind of
stick with that same identity instead of
you know we see maybe like Samsung
phones I look completely different every
single time but with an iphone it's very
clear these are all iphones so i think
it's smart on that front but it makes it
you know kind of less exciting for us i
guess you know we're not going to see
some crazy out there design mat Honan
our own mat Honan wrote about this all
right after the launch and i agree with
what he said which is that before a big
event like this there's the height so
huge and there's so many expectations
and everybody I think people tend to
project their own you know wants onto
the announcement like it doesn't have
NFC but I really really wanted it to
have NFC well you know there's probably
a good reason why it doesn't have NFC
and you know people can't see past their
own like wants and desires in that space
so I mean Apple is always in this weird
position where they're not really
creating a device that they're creating
the device that they know is going to be
best for them and best for their
customers but of course it's not the
device that everybody wants right yeah
and I know and some of these other
phones have come out like the Lumia 920
have these fancy features like wireless
charging an NFC and they're just they're
not really fully implemented in the
world yet so I mean even if you had it
in the phone you can't really take
advantage of it
where you go and so I feel like apples
not going to hop on the train with
anything like that until it is something
you can use everywhere you yeah that's a
good point those things are really
successful in niche products but for the
mainstream maybe not quite there yeah
and when we get our review unit in of
course we'll be able to tell you a lot
more about the phone itself things like
the LTE performance things like battery
life screen you know what the screen
looks and feels like all that stuff and
Christine is going to be the one telling
you all about that so we have that to
look forward to in the meantime there's
some new headphones that come with it
yes and nathan has those and he's going
to tell us all about them
so for the last 10 years or so this has
been the thing right the white wires
that come with every ipod every iphone
well that is about to change yes the
iconic earbuds are being replaced with
earpods this is truly a new day consumer
technology this is an amazing
breakthrough will actually no it's just
they're just really nice headphones
they're still 29 bucks they fit much
nicer in my ear so they're actually
there there it's sort of like a little
bit in ear more so than yeah yeah design
yeah Apple redesigned their headphones
the free ones you got the iphone and
with the ipod can buy for 29 bucks to
apple store and it has this really slick
shape that fits into your ear canal it
sounds way better you can actually get
some bass no it's not just a muddled
flat mess a lot of detail you can hear
layers of sound i was listening to a lot
of different rock and jazz and hip-hop
and it all sounded good that's cool
these things are fantastic so like i
know a lot of the the bass response on
the high end especially has a lot to do
with the the seal that you get when you
put in here so these forms sort of a
seal these actually have a seal you'll
get the suction that you'll get with a
lot of in your headphones and I'm cool
with that but there's a bunch of
different ports built in around the
headphones that allow air travel through
that gives you a little kind of airflow
chamber to get some bass sure and in a
nicer mid-range to very cool so those
come with a iphone 5 and the newly
redesigned ipods you got it and if you
want to upgrade tomb you just go to the
apple store and you spend 30 bucks yep
it's a fair price yeah that's great I
mean they sound as good as some hundred
dollar in your headphones that I've
tried in the past all right well I'm
gonna take your word for that because
there's no way I'm putting those foul
things in my ears that they've been in
your ears try no no but that's all the
time we have and will be back next week
with another edition of The Gadget Lab
show and of course keep your eyes peeled
on wired.com / reviews for the full
review of the iphone 5 from wired and
until then we'll see you next time